hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Horror Thriller
film called the shallows spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie opens up with a young boy
playing football on a beach in Mexico it
is almost dark and there is no one
around suddenly the boy finds a helmet
with a GoPro attached to it when he
plays the first video we see two Surfers
enjoying the sunny weather and having a
good time however soon they are attacked
by a massive shark which tears them into
pieces the young boy is horrified by
their screams so he immediately flees
the place following this the movie
flashes back to two days earlier where
an American Tourist named Nancy Adams is
heading to the same Beach from her
conversation with the driver we get to
know that she was an aspiring medical
student however after the recent death
of her terminally ill mother she has
decided to change her field of work
Nancy also reveals that her mom got
pregnant on this very Beach and this is
why it is special someday Ryan Reynolds
will get her pregnant on this beach and
they'll give birth to a bottle of gin
and a soccer team after a while they
finally arrive at the beach it is a
stunningly Beauty beautiful place just
like Nancy had envisioned the best thing
is that the beach is almost empty apart
from a few local Surfers once the driver
leaves Nancy quickly changes into her
swimming gear and readies her surfboard
which was left behind by her mother then
she dives into the sea and starts
paddling towards the waves on reaching a
bit further she meets the two Surfers
who seem to be friendly Nancy asks if
she should know anything about the place
and one of them reveals that the
jellyfish found here are very dangerous
he also explains that there are a few
reefs here which only appear in the
evening when the tides are low following
the short conversation the three of them
get on their surfboards and ride through
the waves even Nancy appears to be a pro
a few hours later the boys get tired and
decide to leave however Nancy who has
come all the way from the state wants to
have a little more fun she mentions that
she will be here for a few more hours
and bids them goodbye as soon as the
boys leave though Nancy feels something
approaching her from inside the water
fortunately it's just a pot of dolphins
jumping around in excitement
Nancy is mesmerized by their beauty and
playfulness so she decides to follow
them surprisingly after a few minutes
she notices that the sea is completely
filled with blood it is revealed to be
coming out of a deceased whale which was
probably hunted a few days ago realizing
that a predator is nearby Nancy gets on
her surfboard and starts rushing towards
safety unfortunately the Beast has
already noticed her it strikes the
surfboard and sends her tumbling through
the Rocks somehow Nancy manages to get
back on her surfboard but the Beast
grabs her leg and pulls her inside the
water it is revealed to be a colossal
great white shark in the ensuing
struggle Nancy's leg is badly wounded
because of which the water around her
turns red but despite this she somehow
manages to get away and climbs the whale
carcass once she reaches there Nancy
finally realizes the gravity of the
situation she screams and cries for help
but as expected no one can hear her she
is just too far away from the beach
meanwhile the shark is still hell-bent
on finishing off the Intruder it starts
slamming the whale carcass repeatedly
causing Nancy to almost fall off into
the water hence she decides to find a
more stable surface where she can hide
from the shark she looks around the
place and notices two options the first
one is a buoy floating in the water but
it appears to be too far away the second
option is a reef which is just starting
to appear because of the low tides the
only problem is that it will drown again
the next day Nancy gets into a dilemma
but she eventually chooses the reef
right before the shark Rams the carcass
and sends it flying now she is in the
Water swimming for her life with a
severely injured leg the shark is also
right behind her coming at full speed
the situation seems to be very perilous
but fortunately Nancy manages to make it
to the reef there she meets another one
of the shark's victims a seagull
on it was chilling on the whale carcass
minding its own business when the shark
sent it flying Nancy sympathizes with
the bird but for now she has her own
problems in order to stop the bleeding
in her leg she uses her ornaments and
conducts a makeshift operation the
procedure makes her scream in pain but
little did she know that this is just
the start of a terrifying situation
after stitching up her wound she ties
her wetsuit around it making sure that
it doesn't get infected with that thing
off and surrounded by salt water it is
all but ensured that she and the
audience are going to get real thirsty a
few hours later night comes and it
becomes extremely cold Nancy does some
more modifications to her swimsuit and
turns it into some sort of jacket
however the resilient Gall doesn't need
any of that he simply looks at Nancy
with disapproving eyes probably thinking
that she is a weak ass being later in
the night the two eat some crabs and
bonds together in one instance Nancy
notices her surfboard floating not too
far from her hoping that the shark is
long gone she slowly gets inside the
wall water however when she swims for a
few minutes she notices the great whites
menacing fin looming above the surface
it turns out the shark is still hovering
around the place Nancy uses the last of
her strength and gets back on the reef
but in the process she hurts her leg
again at this point she is almost given
up the reef is going to disappear in a
few hours and if the shark doesn't kill
her her worsening wound probably will
but right then Nancy sees a ray of hope
it is a fat drunk man who is passed out
on the beach since he is not that far
away Nancy screams for help and
fortunately he wakes up she then
instructs him to make a call from her
phone which is kept inside her bag the
man appears to be complying but as soon
as he checks the bag greed sets in right
in front of Nancy's eyes he takes out
all her cash puts her phone in his
pocket and prepares to leave but just
then he notices the surfboard floating
in the water and decides to steal that
as well despite everything that the
greedy man has done Nancy repeatedly
tries to warn him of the danger but to
no avail nobody can see save an idiot
from themselves he gets into the water
and also reaches the surfboard but
before he can return to the shore with
it the shark attacks him tearing him in
half Nancy can just watch in horror
realizing that there is no way out the
next morning she is woken up by a few
water splashes this means that the tides
are rising and in a matter of hours The
Reef will completely sink now Nancy has
to figure out a way to escape this
wretched sea as soon as possible
suddenly the two Surfers from the
previous day arrive at the beach thank
God for unemployed people they
immediately noticed Nancy on the reef
and start approaching her on their
surfboards Nancy tries her best to
explain that a shark is nearby but the
guys who are regulars of this place
believe that she is joking unfortunately
the next second the killer shark leaps
up into the air and gobbles up one of
the Surfers witnessing this his friend
panics no body no and starts swimming
towards Nancy anxiously he eventually
makes it but before she can pull him up
the shark drags him down into the depths
of the sea decide of a human being dying
right in front of her horrifies Nancy
but she knows that she has to be strong
if she wants to see her family again if
only the unemployed had better sense
after a while she picks up the gall and
starts tending to his wounds the little
guy bites her at first obviously annoyed
that three guys have been killed because
of her but after a while he calms down
in the next scene as Nancy is looking
for ways to get off the reef she notices
the second surfer's helmet which has a
GoPro on it this is the same one that we
saw at the start of the movie and
despite the Sharks still circling around
the place Nancy wants to retrieve it
however this time she has an idea in
mind using her watch she calculates the
exact time the shark takes to make a
complete rotation of the reef it turns
out to be 30 seconds shortly after Nancy
waits for an opportune moment and Dives
inside the water she manages to grab the
GoPro without any problem but on the way
back the shark starts chasing her Nancy
somehow gets back on the reef but the
resilient shark tries jumping on the
surface snatch her away fortunately the
sharp rocks and poisonous plants
instantly repel it back inside the water
after yet another near-death experience
Nancy finally has something that will
help her in the middle of the sea a
GoPro even the gall is astounded by her
stupidity nonetheless Nancy doesn't care
she records a message for her family
telling them to stay strong if she dies
in association Nancy then records
another message in which she begs for
help once she is done she Chucks the
GoPro back into the sea hoping that it
will reach the shore where someone will
watch her video and come to her Aid an
hour later it is almost noon the High
Tides will soon arrive and sweep the
reef away now Nancy will have to dive
into the water and reach the buoy at any
cost though the distance to it is 100
meters which will take at least two
minutes to reach Nancy has to make a
move she knows that the shark will most
probably catch up to her but she has to
try before leaving though she puts the
gall into a broken piece of surfboard
and sends it away hoping the waves will
take it to the shore goodbye goodbye
after a while as Nancy braces herself to
dive into the water she notices hundreds
of jellyfish swimming nearby this gives
her an idea she remembers how the
Surfers wonder that these animals are
very dangerous although a risky move
Nancy decides to swim between the
jellyfish and use them as a shield
against the shark the plan works the
shark doesn't dare come near her it
appears to be terrified of the jellies
after a while Nancy finally reaches the
buoy but as she is climbing it the
handle breaks making her fall back into
the water the shark also arrives and it
appears as if it is going to tear her
into pieces however Nancy bravely stabs
it with the piece of metal allowing her
enough time to climb up the buoy after
this she looks through the hidden
compartment and finds a flare gun Nancy
immediately fires it into the sky to
call for help but no one seems to be
around by this time the shark has also
become very aggressive and it repeatedly
keeps banging on the buoy it is only a
matter of minutes before it sinks so
with time running out she comes up with
yet another plan Nancy realizes that the
nearby whale carcass has started leaking
oil so she fires the remaining flare
into the ocean as soon as she does so
the water lights up igniting the shark
as well the massive Beast struggles for
a while but then it Dives inside the
water and extinguishes the fire it
appears as if nothing can put it down
meanwhile on the shore the boy who is
playing soccer at the start of the movie
has finally found the GoPro after going
through the videos he immediately runs
to call for help back at the buoy the
shark has become even more aggressive
and it is constantly ramming the buoy
bit by bit it disintegrates the large
structure and eventually takes it off
balance now Nancy is hanging on for dear
life only a small piece of metal lies
between her and the shark at one point
the buoy goes underwater and this is
when Nancy notices the anchor that is
holding it located at the bottom of the
sea the anchor is made up of several
pointy rods which gives her yet another
idea so while the shark is still
attacking the buoy she gets out of it
and disconnects the chain the chain is
so heavy that it starts pulling Nancy to
the depths of the ocean the shark
finally notices this and starts
following her now Nancy has to make her
final move although the plan can easily
result in her death it is her only shot
so she waits until the very last second
and lets go of the chain Nancy misses
the sharp anchor by inches but the shark
is not so lucky it gets pierced through
and through resulting in an instant
death in the next scene the boy finally
arrives with his father who is none
other than the driver from earlier he
spots a lifeless Nancy on the shore and
immediately starts administering CPR
fortunately she wakes up a few seconds
later making everyone happy even the
gull is there he cheers around from the
sidelines you're fine you're fine
seriously you're you're fine following
this the movie cuts to one year later
Nancy is seen at a beach in Texas she is
healed from her injuries leaving only a
few scars on her legs Nancy has also
resumed her studies and is on her way to
becoming a doctor soon the movie ends as
she along with her sister jump into the
sea probably to Kickstart part 2 of the
movie
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching